let's go to Stoney from Indiana Stoney
from Indiana welcome to the program uh
what's on your mind today
yeah
yeah hey David uh can you hear me yes I
can Stoney welcome
awesome thank you
um yeah so I had a question obviously uh
either whether you're a Republican or
Democrat everyone knows funding is how
our system runs
um I find it interesting in a state like
Indiana for example uh with the
overturning of Roe v wave there's no
real way to support that other than
donating to
a certain non-profit organizations but
for example there's fundraising through
like license plates so there's you know
Riley's Children's Hospitals they even
have one for Tony Stewart who's you know
a murderer as we all know
um but there's nothing for abortion so
do you know why that is or how you can
change that I don't so just so I
understand Stoney you're talking about
how in some states there's these like
pro-life license plates where when you
choose it it's like I remember up in
Massachusetts you could get one that was
like Cape Cod and the islands and a
little money went to conservation or you
could get one that was whatever else
you're saying that there there are
states where you're basically a portion
of your vanity plate goes to an
anti-abortion charity but you've never
seen one that goes to a pro-choice
organization uh exactly I haven't either
and I don't know the answer to I don't
know why I genuinely have no idea why
I I've seen uh there I've done a bit of
research on it but it's a bit convoluted
there's uh around 14 States or so that
offer something around that range that
offers some sort of pro-life sort of
plate
um I I believe I I mean I'm not a lawyer
but from what I've read if you have like
a non-profit organization they can
submit and have it approved and it
started of course in Florida with uh uh
Jeb Bush sued and got it overturned it's
it's got an interesting history but from
what I've been able to gather the only
states that you can really find this in
are obviously like California and Oregon
and places like that
um but in you know the Midwest for
example you can't you can find religious
vanity plates you can we have you know
60 different available options to us
even the Boy Scouts Girl Scouts Etc uh
but there's nothing for us everyday
people to a support pro-life and B uh be
able to I think you mean support
pro-choice right you mentioned
pro-choice yes yes correct correct yeah
I mean listen if it's as you describe
then it sounds like it requires the
activism of submitting and then getting
enough votes to make that an option in
States it could I don't know enough
about it but if that's the case it's a
question of of getting an activist
campaign going to demand it
yes I I agree I think it's just one
simple way we can give back
um for that so yeah thank you very much
David all right Stoney from Indiana
thank you very much for the call I
appreciate that why don't we go next
just I mean listen we're taking calls
we're all here we're connected let's
just talk to a few other people let's go
to Elon from New York Elon from New York
welcome to the program what's going on
can you hear me yes I can
okay uh you recently talked about incorp
about including nuclear energy as a way
to combat climate change and as more
interest in nuclear energy starts to
grow do you think that maybe we should
start considering thorium as an energy
source have you heard of thorium I've
heard about it I don't know enough about
it to be able to really say you know we
did an interview about
um you know fission and fusion and the
advancement there and we've talked about
new nuclear as a bridge to totally
renewable uh green energy Etc I I just
don't know enough about Thorium to
intelligently weigh in on it
oh can I give you some examples as what
I've heard just came and convince you
yeah I mean so are you actually
knowledgeable enough but you're not just
spitballing here you actually know about
it
I did some research on it I'm a physics
major and I studied um
some did some read some articles on
Dorian okay tell me what it is explain
to me in the simplest terms this is a
real test of whether one understands
something whether you can explain it in
really simple terms
authorium is uh as well as a territorium
on the periodic table is
you know is atomic number is number 90.
it's three times more available to the
planet than uranium it's easier to mine
it has higher concentrations in its or
than uranium
and one of the things that scientists
are saying that
it's that science study says is that
it's that's well that with plutonium it
can produce up to 30 pounds more energy
than uranium okay and which is up to two
times more which is two point mil by one
ton of door young can produce up to 2.5
million
and one ton of thorium is equal to clear
enough energy equivalent to 2.5 million
tons of coal
and it's much more cleaner and efficient
than
um than um
I call my name is but that's what I'm
pulling from from my brain okay well
listen I mean it sounds interesting I
don't know that right now I'm going to
learn enough about it to be able to
weigh in but let me research it
okay it's just an interesting topic and
I feel that with nuclear energy being
more acceptable particularly I'm not
sure how much the left accepted I think
we should consider all our options
instead of just I know we're a fan of
renewable energy but I think we should
consider all our options in regarding a
serious issue like climate change we
should always consider all of our
options that I'm with you
okay uh and also a quick question
um now that um now that we're heading
into the 224
um election season
do you think
what other methods what main methods do
you think the left needs to improve on
in terms of marketing they're
ensure that whatever candidates or
whatever their agenda is for the
upcoming elections day so before we even
get to tactics before we even get the
tactics the left has to dramatically
improve its messaging and decide on
exactly what the platform and the and
the sales pitch essentially is going to
be the left is a little bit all over the
place on that before we even talk about
marketing tactics they got they got to
figure that out all right my friend I
appreciate the call thank you so much
I thank you have a good day all right a
lot of things on people's minds today
very very much things on people's minds
which is important